[Music]
hey you guys time once again for another
book review
now as i promised uh this is actually
the third book in a trilogy
and i think when i did the last book the
second book in the trilogy uh you know
which was called the hungry ones i was
kind of like yeah i'm definitely going
to read the third one as soon as
possible because
these books
other than the first one i kind of feel
like the first one you can just read as
a standalone but if you're gonna read
the trilogy i would recommend reading
them not only in order but also reading
them like pretty close together because
it's kind of cool because these books
are so like the mythology around it is
like so complex like the story you know
and each one kind of explores different
facets of it that if you don't read the
whole thing kind of one after the other
then you might lose it or not get as
much like appreciation for it so the
book i'm talking about today is the
third book in chris sorensen's messy man
series and this one is just called the
messy man so like i said uh i reviewed
the first one the nightmare room which
came out in 2018
and after i guess uh the author chris
sorensen saw my review of it and uh was
very appreciative because i thought it
was an awesome book and so he offered to
send me the second and third ones in the
series for free so of course i was like
uh yeah free books we all love that and
especially when they're as awesome as
these ones so yeah and he like even
signed it and like drew little ghosties
in there and stuff which i thought was
like super cute but yeah he's a he's a
lovely person and a really nice uh man
and a really really good writer uh so
this one like i said the cool thing
about this
is that because even though i read the
hungry ones the second book not too long
ago i'm trying to remember because i put
up a review of that one too and i feel
like it wasn't that long ago it was
probably like a few months ago and i was
like yeah i really gotta get to the
messy man like really quick because i
still remembered like most of the stuff
that happened in the second one like i
said this is one that you really need to
read them all in order and read them
close together because it's like so
they're so rich in detail that if you
kind of like leave a long time in
between or something like that you're
gonna like not get as much appreciation
maybe but this i really like this and i
don't remember that i don't think the
second one had this he actually in the
very back of the book he gives you like
a little nice uh synopsis there's a
little synopsis of the nightmare room
and uh you know then there's a little
synopsis of the hungry ones case you
need like kind of a refresher which was
actually much appreciated because even
though like i said i remembered most of
the story but it was kind of nice to
have some of this stuff so it jogged my
memory a little bit now so the
interesting thing about this so like i
said the nightmare room
is based around a couple peter and
hannah who their son michael had died of
cancer and uh they moved to like back to
this um
to his hometown maple city and they end
up moving into like to take care of his
dad who's you know in a home and they
end up uh you know
moving into
the dad's old farm house and like fixing
it up and the place is kind of like
haunted now so the first one is sort of
like
a haunted house story but
with a little bit of a different twist
in it in
regards to what the haunting actually is
and like i said i don't really want to
spoil it it's hard to talk about like
without spoiling everything but it's not
it's not exactly a ghost there's like
some other kind of stuff going on and
like i said it's the mythology behind
this is like really cool um and it's
something that you don't see in a lot of
haunted house novels so the first one
would like i said you could read
the first one you could totally read as
a standalone uh story but like i said if
you're gonna do the trilogy then you
just kind of have to like go all the way
with it but like i said each of the
books
is its own thing but
i kind of feel like particularly maybe
not so much with this one but with
particularly with the second one the
hungry ones i kind of feel like you have
to have read the first book
before you read that one like i don't
think you could read the hungry ones
like on its own
and or i mean you might be able to but i
kind of felt like uh you'd be like what
is going on or you wouldn't really get
like i said you wouldn't really get
anything as much out of it i think
uh so the hungry ones like i said kind
of did a little thing with i'm trying
not to
spoil the whole thing that it did but it
uh it did kind of a thing with time
displacement where
you it was kind of focused on a
different character like this woman
named jessie and her friend who bought
this rundown hotel
or motel rather like a motor lodge in
maple city where this mass shooting like
a massacre had taken place then you had
like peter and hannah and michael who is
alive because it's like a different
timeline uh and then they kind of like
come there and start living there and
then they have like a haunting
experience too but again not exactly
like ghosts they're almost kind of like
i don't even want to call them demons
it's not really that it's just kind of
like
sort of like a ghost but they were never
people but they can kind of inhabit
people and like some of them like eat
ghosts and things like that so it's like
a whole uh thing
so this one the messy man
uh peter is a character in this as well
uh but
i kind of like that the narrative is
split like pretty much 50 50
between peter's what he's doing now
uh and the character of ellen marks now
ellen marks uh was a character in the
first two books as well she's like a
paranormal investigator uh you know who
can talk to ghosts and she kind of like
they're talking to her all the time
honestly even though she wasn't in the
first two books a lot like she's just
her character makes like a big
impression she's like a really really
good character and it's like easily my
favorite character in the series
and uh so i was just like yeah we need
more of her so i guess that uh chris
sorensen maybe heard that because
everybody's talking about how cool a
character she was so pretty much 50 of
this book maybe more uh maybe 60 70
percent is following ellen marks but
it's only it's following ellen marks
back in 2003 when she was 11 years old
now you might think that that sounds
like oh man but it's actually really
really good because honestly if you read
the first two books in the series and
you know like one a kind of like
very like strange
abrasive and yet also quite awesome
chick like ellen marx's
she's
still like that like in her kid form uh
she's still very much like that like her
personality is very much like that so i
really really like i think it was a
great decision to focus on
on her character for this even though
she's kind of a little kid but like i
said she's her personality is still
you know noticeably her
and i like too that
her thing that she's doing is kind of
like there's some paranormal ghost stuff
going on with her thing too because it's
almost kind of like
her
coming to terms are like discovering
like how she you know can talk to ghosts
and how she's learning to deal with it
like as a child
um so you got that aspect of it too but
then there's also it's almost kind of
like a mystery story so it's like really
really cool but then it kind of goes
back and forth with peter too because if
you'll remember if you read these books
at the end of the second book
peter had been like thrown back and he
was like going back in time because like
i said there's a lot of
there's a lot of stuff in this where
it's not exactly time travel but
where you can kind of go back and
there's like different uh you know
timelines and it's sad it's so it's a
little bit complicated to follow but
it's not like hard sci-fi or anything
like that but it's just kind of a thing
where you know like i said the beginning
of the hungry ones where you're seeing
you know peter and hannah and their son
michael uh who in one timeline the kid
died
but then because peter like went back
and
and did something like with the with the
spirit that was inhabit like the dark
spirit that was inhabiting him like he
was actually able to go back and sort of
kind of
sacrifice himself in a way but not
physically if that makes any sense like
i said it's there's a lot of paranormal
stuff and it's kind of complicated to
explain without spoiling too much about
it
but he was able to kind of sacrifice a
part of himself so that his son could
live so there's like an alternate
timeline so that's kind of what's going
on in this one too so peter's timeline
so ellen's timeline is in 2003 at least
until
you know toward the end like the third
act like when their uh timelines
intertwine
but peter
is i believe in
1979 like so he got thrown back to
um cause like i said and this isn't i
don't know this isn't necessarily a
spoiler because at the end of the second
book like he woke up like in this
circle of stones and there was a young
girl there and it was willa now willa i
think is his mom
uh so he's seeing his mom as a kid so
it's just kind of like so we're
following peter's story him in 1979 and
he's kind of turned up on the grounds of
this kind of old abandoned church
and there's this old guy who looks kind
of like santa claus named papa fallow
and he's he has like all these
kind of kids like orphan kids that he's
sort of like adopted that he's like
taking care of and they all have
different sort of paranormal kind of
powers you know what i mean like willa
can
summon
uh whisper
you know that which is like i said it's
not a demon it's more like a dark spirit
but not it's not bad it's like helpful
usually
uh and then like one uh you know one of
the kids can like heal people and like
one of the kids can like make
butterflies like you know they all have
like kind of different sort of quote
unquote magical powers not in a harry
pottery kind of way but you know just in
a little paranormal type of way so he
has this brood of uh kids and so peter's
dealing with that you know so while
that's going on then we're also going
back and forth with ellen marx's story
which like i said is almost kind of more
like a mystery because she's 11 years
old uh her father who she was
the closest that she loved him more than
anything in the world and she was like
closer to him than anybody uh he has
passed away in a car accident
like i think it was a year prior
and um she's still really upset about it
so she's living with her
single mom who to be honest is
it's not really the greatest she's not
like
physically abusive or anything like that
but she's always just kind of like you
know why just saying to the kid like why
are you so weird why can't you be normal
um so and she's a real
you know she's always like
looking out for the next dude like you
know jumping on the dick and
uh you know she's super super cheap like
she just wants to buy all ellen's
clothes that she's going to like thrift
stores not thrift stores but like garage
sales and [ __ ] like that she's always
kind of like yelling at her for being a
weirdo
and so ellen has obviously uh kind of
closed up and is not so is not real uh
forthcoming with her mom about these
burgeoning like uh psychic powers or
whatever or you know or you know she's
actually kind of a medium actually
because i guess she can see ghosts and
they talk to her and ask her for help
and stuff so what ends up happening that
sort of kicks off ellen marx's journey
as an 11 year old is she gets a birthday
card from that is ostensibly from her
dad even though her dad has been dead
for a year and it's got money in it and
everything
so uh she thinks this is really weird
and while they're at um obviously she
doesn't tell her mom because her mom
would be like your dad's dead what the
[ __ ] uh so yeah so she gets the card and
then with the money like her mom takes
hers like oh we need to buy you some new
clothes for school because your stuff
doesn't fit anymore so they go to like
these all these garage sales and ellen
finds this sort of like a reel to reel
uh tape recorder type thing
and uh she really like she's very drawn
to it and she really wants it so she
kind of sneaks off and buys it and takes
it in a room and when she listens to it
it's all these weird little um
the the little uh reels like the little
recordings all seem to be like people
singing hymns and stuff but then
when um
she
listens to one of them like the one that
she's kind of attracted to
there's
kind of a screaming voice on it uh
saying her name
and also saying something about blind
rock she is so the so what happens is
she kind of becomes convinced like
through some clues that keep uh popping
up that her dead father
is
leading her on this particular journey
so pretty much it's her
um trying to figure out like how she's
gonna get to maple city with our mom
finding out about it because she wants
to find out like what this mystery is
what's blind rock why is my dad
um you know why do i think my dad is
giving me signs like he wants me to go
there uh you know what i mean because
she's like 11 years old so she has to
like be wily and like figure out a way
to do this um so honestly those were
like the the part with peter was good
too uh because he's like a really good
character but it's the thing about peter
is that because he's in all three books
but because
sometimes it's like a different timeline
or it's a different like iteration of
him um so he's not like as you know and
this isn't a criticism i'm just saying
that he's not like a consistent
character because he's always kind of
well he you know it's like well is is
this the timeline where his son is dead
or is this a timeline where son's alive
or is this the timeline where he's sort
of merged with
whisper like his uh or mr tell his dark
spirit is he merged with that so it's so
he's kind of like a little bit different
he's like so you know he's somewhat
consistent but it's always kind of like
a different thing whereas ellen marks is
a very consistent character and even
though she's just a kid in this um she's
very recognizably
the um you know the paranormal
investigator character from the first
two so like i said i think it's really
really cool uh that we're focusing on
her this time around like most of the
time so i mean her and her journey even
though like she's seeing ghosts and
she's following clues and stuff like
that you get uh another appearance by
riggs who was
who owned i think he owned the bar in
the first book that uh that hannah
worked at
the blind rock tavern and he's a really
good character too he's also in this one
he kind of works in the library where
ellen goes in maple city and like kind
of helps her uh you know do some
research into what is going on like with
this whole blind rock thing that she
keeps seeing because she keeps seeing
like you know and this kind of goes back
to the first couple books too it's just
like this big massacre
that went on on this particular piece of
ground of people that
kind of had magical powers so it was
this kind of thing so that's kind of
like um where
peter and ellen's story in this converge
you know what i mean like on this
particular patch of ground where this
massacre happened i think back in the
1800s or whatever or was it earlier i
kind of want to say it was 1800s but
maybe it's now i can't remember but yeah
honestly i'm gonna say all of the books
are good and it's like and i just feel
like
it's cool because even though it's a
it's very obviously a trilogy all of the
stories are interconnected but each book
is it's
i don't want to say it's his own thing
because you kind of have to read them
all like to
get the gist of everything but i'm just
saying that each one has its own
particular kind of vibe a particular
kind of style like i said like the first
one
the nightmare room was kind of
you know more like a haunted house story
with a twist whereas the second one was
kind of like i guess it was like haunted
motel but it wasn't exactly that i mean
it was ghost but then there was all this
other kind of like
stuff going on like in the you know in
the spirit dimension and there was all
that kind of stuff going on too uh
whereas this one is kind of like part of
the stuff in the spirit world uh part
historical
uh you know the about the massacre and
everything and then most of it the ellen
marks part is just like a creepy like
paranormal mystery like while she's
going on this journey like trying to
find out what it is that her dead father
is trying to tell her and honestly that
was my favorite part of it
all the books are good this might ooh i
was gonna say i think this might be my
favorite one of the series it's hard to
say because they're all so good i mean
the nightmare room was so good and uh
that keep that came out back in 2018 and
it's amazing how much like attention
that got when it came out because it's
like yeah on its surface it's kind of
like oh it's a haunted house story but
it was like way more than that like the
mythology and that book's so great the
second one's great honestly i think
because this one focuses on ellen mark's
largely who i think was my favorite
character well i know it was my favorite
character from the whole trilogy um so i
think this one maybe has the edge
over it just because it's just i don't
know it's just so fun like
like watching her like go through the
mystery of like trying to figure out
because you you know you have to think
even though
her character you know equivalent in the
other books was older and had already
well established uh you know her talent
for talking to ghosts and seeing them um
it's kind of interesting to see her
talent like burgeoning and for her like
learning to deal with it because she's
like an 11 year old kid and she sees
like horrible things like she'll see
like a massacre she'll see like a man on
fire or something like that like she
sees things that happened in the past
and it's like horrifying for her and she
has to like learn to deal with that so i
think that was like a really good idea
like a really good angle
to come at it so it wasn't just kind of
like more of the same it's the same
character but you're coming at it from a
different perspective and i thought that
was like a really really good uh that
was a really really good thing to do
because like i said it changed
everything up but
everything in all three books still ties
together which honestly now that i'm
thinking about it is like really really
amazing um but that it just like that
everything ties up because this is a
pretty complex
mythology and a pretty complex story
like i said there's multiple
timelines we're like jumping back and
forth in time it's not hor it's not
terribly hard to follow i didn't find it
that hard to follow but there is a lot
of detail there is a lot of
intertwining timelines and characters
and stuff that you kind of have to keep
track of to get all the appreciation out
of it so i think that's why it's cool
that he put like the uh you know the
summaries of the first two books back
here just in case like i said i
remembered them but it was good to have
kind of like some of the details and
here i was just like oh yeah that's that
person or whatever and that's that
timeline or whatever but yeah honestly
like the more i'm thinking about it like
i said it's oh i really hate to say but
i think this might be my favorite one of
the series like i said just because i
love the ellen mark's character i love
i loved like her whole journey and i
love how everything tied together
in the end which
is like i said it's kind of amazing
because these are
these are like three kind of disparate
books or different types of books i
guess they're so horror they're still
paranormal but they kind of each had a
different perspective or they each had a
different thing going on but in the end
everything is like wrapped up you know
what i mean and everything is all tied
together and i thought that was like
really really awesome but yeah seriously
if you haven't read these you really
should like i said the first book the
nightmare room from 2018
is awesome and it's like that would be
the only one that you could just read
like on its own like one and done uh but
if you're gonna do the whole trilogy
which i would recommend because it is
really is like a whole
rich complex story and it's really cool
like how the threads tie together then
definitely read them in order and
definitely read them just one right
after the other so it's like one big
long thing but uh yeah i think this
might be my favorite so
honestly it's just like that's pretty
kick ass
the third one is like the best one but
yeah it's pretty great uh so yeah check
them all out if you haven't if you have
uh let me know what you thought about
them which one's your favorite uh you
know just let's have a discussion about
it in the comments that will do it for
this tomes of terror book review and i
will see you guys on the next one bye